Experience Amazing
at your Lexus Dealer.
>> Greg: LAST WEEK,
HILLARY CLINTON SMEARED MILLIONS
OF WOMEN.
>> WE DO NOT DO WELL WITH WHITE
MEN AND WE DON'T DO WELL WITH
MARRIED WHITE WOMEN.
PART OF THAT IS AN
IDENTIFICATION WITH THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND A SORT OF
ONGOING PRESSURE TO VOTE THE WAY
THAT YOUR HUSBAND, YOUR BOSS,
YOUR SON, WHOEVER BELIEVES YOU
SHOULD.
>> Greg: THOSE EVIL WHITE MEN.
INSTEAD OF LETTING THINGS LIKE A
MISTAKE A FRONT END LOADER AND
DUG A HOLE SO DEEP.
SHE SAID SHE MEANT NO
DISRESPECT.
SHE IS SO COOL AS SHE GOT
COMMENTS MADE IN INDIA WOULDN'T
TRAVEL.
SHE ADDED "I DID NOT REALIZE HOW
HARD IT WOULD HIT MANY WHO HEARD
IT."
DO YOU SEE WHAT SHE DID?
THE JAB AND HIDE OF A BITTER
TROLL WHO TWEETS YOU ARE FAT
FOLLOWED BY WOW, I GUESS I
STRUCK A NERVE.
WHEN SHE CALLS WOMEN SUBMISSIVE
MORONS, THEIR RESPONSE MEANS SHE
HAS TO BE RIGHT.
YOU COULD SAY GREG, YOU'VE
ENJOYED HILLARY'S DECLINE TOO
MUCH.
YOU WOULD BE RIGHT.
I AM THINKING WE DODGED A
BULLET.
EVERY TIME SHE SPEAKS, SHE
REMINDS YOU WHY SHE LOST WHAT
SHE THINKS OF YOU.
HILLARY'S RAGE IS JUST A
PROJECTION.
DECADES OF DOING HER ASPENS
SUBMISSIVE BIDDING, IT DIDN'T
PAY OFF.
THE WORLD IS AN UNJUST PLACE IN
HER VENGEFUL STATE.
I DESERVE TO BE PRESIDENT, SHE
THINKS, AFTER ENDURING THE
HUMILIATIONS OF BILL'S BETRAYAL.
ONE MAN MADE HER FEEL VERY SMALL
AND SHE REPAYS THAT SENTIMENT A
MILLION FOLD ON THE FEMALE TRUMP
VOTER, MANY OF WHOM VOTED FOR
OBAMA.
IT IS PAYBACK DELIVERED TO THE
WRONG PEOPLE.
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU         W
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU         A
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU         O
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU         Y
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU         U
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU         D
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU         O
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU         W
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU         T
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO YOU         A
GUEST WHO WILL NOT LEAVE?
I HEAR THERE IS A BRIGHT YOUNG
FACE ON THE HORIZON.
>> IN 2016, IT WASN'T THEIR YEAR
BUT IN 2020, THE DEMOCRATS WILL
UNLEASH A BRAND-NEW CANDIDATE TO
LEAD THE RESISTANCE OF VICTORY.
SOMEONE WITH A NEW VISION FOR
AMERICA.
A FREEDOM FIGHTER, A FRESH FACE,
A GRASSROOTS HERO.
HER NAME, HILLARY CLINTON.
THIS UP-AND-COMER IS BITTER,
MEAN, CRANKY, VINDICTIVE, ALL
THE THINGS YOU WANT AND A RISING
STAR.
IN FOUR DECADES, SHE'S GIVEN SO
MUCH TO REAL AMERICANS.
THINGS LIKE HUGS, FACES,
FASHIONS, TOTALLY NORMAL
LAUGHTER.
THIS LONG LIST OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
WOW.
VOTE HILLARY CLINTON IN 2020.
SHE IS NEW BUT SHE WILL GROW ON
YOU.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU WERE RIGHT.
I DON'T WANT HER TO GO AWAY.
I CAN'T LIVE WITHOUT HILLARY.
THAT'S WHY HILLARY 2020, JUAN,
GET ON THE BUS.
>> Juan: IS THAT IT?
HERE IS THE BAD NEWS.
SHE WASN'T ELECTED.
SHE'S NOT PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHY MOST OF AMERICA IS
FOCUSED ON -- I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE THINK OH, MY GOD.
SO THE CHAOS IS OKAY.
HILLARY CLINTON WASN'T WRONG.
THERE ARE STUDIES THAT SHOW
EXACTLY WHAT SHE SAID TO BE
TRUE.
LIKE DICK DURBIN SAID, GUESS
WHAT?
THIS WASN'T HELPFUL.
IN FACT IT FEEDS THE RIGHT WING
GRIEVANCE.
OH, HILLARY CLINTON.
THEN YOU HAVE KELLYANNE CONWAY
SEEN SHE IS NOT A FEMINIST.
SHE DOES NOT BELIEVE IN WOMEN.
NUMBER SHIFT AND WOMEN CAN FEEL
INFLUENCED BY HUSBANDS BUT IT
MIGHT BE THE CASE WHERE WOMEN
AGREE WITH THEIR HUSBANDS.
>> Greg: IT'S FUNNY.
IT'S A ONE-WAY STREET.
IF A WOMAN COULD INFLUENCE HER
HUSBAND, THAT'S A GOOD THING BUT
IF A HUSBAND INFLUENCES THE
WIFE, BAD THING.
>> Kimberly: NORMS OF
RECIPROCITY, EQUALITY,
COMMUNICATING.
HILLARY JUST CAN'T HELP HERSELF.
SHE LOVES BEING HILLARY.
SHE'S VERY CONSISTENT IN TERMS
OF HER MESSAGING, WHAT SHE SAID.
I THINK SHE WAS BEING HONEST.
I'M GLAD SHE WAS BEING
TRANSPARENT.
SHE TELLS US EXACTLY WHAT SHE
THINKS.
THAT'S FINE.
IT'S NO PROBLEM.
SHE WANTS TO TELL THEM PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY MARRIED WOMEN AND
WHITE MEN, THAT SHE IS
DISAPPOINTED IN THEIR CHOICES.
ALL RIGHT.
THEY CAN MAKE CHOICES BASED ON
YOUR INFORMATION YOU ARE PUTTING
OUT THERE.
IT'S NOT HELPING THE PARTY.
>> Greg: YOU SEE THAT WHEN
SOMEBODY WILL INSULT YOU.
THEN YOU GO WAIT A SECOND.
>> Dana: I AM SORRY YOU FELT
THAT WAY.
THAT'S THE WORST WAY TO ARGUE
WITH A SPOUSE, BY THE WAY.
THE OTHER THING IS SHE REFUSES
TO TALK ABOUT POLICIES.
THE POLICY CHOICES ARE
PREFERABLE FOR REPUBLICAN WOMEN
TO VOTE FOR REPUBLICANS,
REGARDLESS OF WHO IT IS.
JOSH HAWLEY, THE CANDIDATE
RUNNING AGAINST CLAIRE
McCASKILL, HE HAS JUST CUT AND
ADD USING ALL OF THE STUFF FROM
HILLARY CLINTON AND IT'S PRETTY
EFFECTIVE.
NOW THEY CAN GO AFTER PELOSI AND
HILLARY.
>> Greg: JESSE, THE IRONY IS,
SHE DID JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING
BILL TOLD HER TO DO.
>> Jesse: NOT EVERYTHING.
THIS WAS A TYPICAL POLITICIAN
APOLOGY.
I AM SORRY YOU MISUNDERSTOOD ME.
YOU IDIOT.
THAT'S THE KIND OF APOLOGY SHE
MADE.
SHE ONLY APOLOGIZED BECAUSE
PEOPLE LIKE DURBIN CRITICIZED
HER FOR IT.
SHE WOULDN'T HAVE SAID ANYTHING
IF NO ONE HAD RAISE THE ISSUE ON
THE RIGHT.
WAS BECAUSE OF PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT THAT SHE HAD TO SAY IT.
I DON'T THINK SHE SHOULD HAVE IT
ALL.
I AGREE WITH KIMBERLY, IT SHOWS
WEAKNESS.
IF SHE IS SHOOTING FROM THE HIP
AND BEING AUTHENTIC HILLARY, LET
IT RIP.
THE BOOK, YOU SAID EVERYTHING
YOU HAD TO SAY.
GO TO INDIA.
MAKE IT RAIN.
I DON'T CARE.
IT'S WHAT SHE REALLY THINKS.
WE LIKE AUTHENTIC HILLARY, EVEN
THOUGH IT IS AUTHENTICALLY
PATHETIC.
THE FACEBOOK APOLOGY WAS